طب لماذا لم تعد الولايات المتحده هي
القوه المهيمنه في مجال البحث والتطوير في
جميع انحاء العالم كما كانت لماذا تعتبرها
عرضه للمفاجاه التقنيه
هذه
الطلعه على الجامعات الامريكيه مؤخرا
العلوم الطبيعه والرياضيه فقدت او فقدت
الاهتمام بها بشكل كبير نحن نشتكي من
الطلبه الصينيين
التكنولوجيا ولكن يحق لنا ان نقول بان
ادوارهم
محاصره ادوارهم ايجابيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه المساله الاخرى هي الغرور
الامريكي
هذه المشكله تواجه الامم التي اعتلت القمه
لفتره طويله جدا مثال شخصي مثلا تقدمت
لمنحه منذ فتره لدراسه
البرمجيات لمعالجه اللغات الطبيعيه ورفضت
المنحه لان الوكاله الحكوميه الامريكيه
ادعت انها تعرف كل ما هنالك وكل ما هو
ضروري حول التكنولوجيا المفتوحه وهذه هي
العقليه التي تؤثر علينا بشكل سلبي هنا
ما الذي يعيق قدره الولايات المتحده على
مراقبه الذكاء الاصطناعي وتطورات الاخرى
عاليه التقنيه في الصين او في اي مكان اخر
في العالم
نفس الغرور الذي وصفته قبل قليل نحن
تقريبا ان المتقدمون جدا وليس من الضروري
ان نبذل الجهد او ان استثمر والسبب الاخر
وانا لا اتحدث عن الولايات المتحده بل
الاستخبارات الغربيه بشكل عام كلها منحازه
تجاهها المعلومات السريه
ويجمع المعلومات مصادر المفتوحه ويحللونها
ولكن هي اقل نسبيا ولا اخذها على نفس
الجديه كما ياخذون المعلومات السريه
وبالتالي او نتيجه لذلك فهناك ميزانيات
اقل واراده اضعف
لوضعه البرامج الخاص بمراقبه مصادر
المفتوحه لتكنولوجيا الاجنبيه هذا شيء لم
يفعلوه من قبل